we had a comment come in from Breanna
and she wrote I like screenwriting but
my dialogue always seems boring and I
never know what to add
how can you spice up dialogue what's
your reaction to that dialogue you know
writing good dialogue is it's a bit of
an arcane art as much as screenwriting
as a craft there's there's there's a
dark art to it and sometimes these
things just have to come to you
what one good trick is to try and keep
your sentences as short as possible
which forces you to write in a punchy er
fashion that's that's something that
that I guess I learned from my
journalist father although honestly I
tend to break that rule a lot so I'm
probably a bit hypocritical there maybe
you're rebelling maybe maybe I did that
enough you know there's an old rule that
you leave you enter scene as late as
possible and you leave it as early as
possible and you make sure that you hit
the main point of that scene and if you
keep that in mind that will also tend to
focus your dialogue remembering who your
characters are just trying to I mean
what I do is I tend to be the hero you
know in in the first sharknado I didn't
know I am ziering was going to play Finn
so that character was just me what would
I do if I were thrown into this insane
is the situation and so then I I write
as my ideal self what would I like to
say in in that situation what would I
like to do you know because in in
everyday life we all have these moments
where somebody says something to us and
we just go and we don't know what to say
and then ten minutes later it comes to
you what you should have said to that
person and the beauty of screenwriting
is you can wait ten minutes until you
figure it out and then write it down
you